[Music]
how honest can i be oh 100
are you positive oh yeah
the type of yelling you're describing is
abuse
and it is trauma
his ex-wife
walked out on him
maybe this is all coming together james
we should start a podcast
[Music]
what are you doing
this is john with the dr john doloni's
show i'm so glad you're here with us
seriously what are you doing with your
life
of all the podcasts you picked this one
actually i'm really glad that you did if
you want to be on the show go to
johndaloni.com
ask ask
johnny.com ask or give us a shout leave
a message at
oh 1-844-693-3291 closer that song's
stuck in my head man you know what else
is stuck in my head
it's
nine o'clock on let's go to chance in
fort worth hey chance what's up
hey dr john um
where
microphone smells like a beer i keep got
that song in my head man oh actually i'm
in front of a microphone it doesn't
really smell like a beer i'm just
singing that song piano man it's the
best chance i'm all over the place today
but you sound like you are i have both
feet on the ground so what's up how can
i help
well that's the first well
welcome to the gang
so i got married about eight months ago
and i'm struggling to balance my own
mental physical
health and
my hobbies and what my personal goals as
well as taking care of my wife and
making sure she's emotionally fulfilled
and taken care of
like that's been really hard
so when you say really hard uh expound
on that a little bit what does that mean
well
so pretty much since
as soon as we got married she has been
dealing with some health issues that
popped up seemingly out of nowhere what
what what type of health issues
uh her immune system isn't the best okay
so she's been getting breaking out in a
lot of hives and just been needing a lot
of extra care basically okay uh
which is i mean i'm more than happy to
take care of her and i love that i can
and i'm that we're here but it's just
hard for me to do that and then also go
and get my exercise or you know pick up
a couple extra hours at work and
uh
do the things that i also need to do in
order to function yeah
so sounds like you had a picture of what
eight months into marriage is going to
be like and the world threw you a
curveball
the if if it's just me and you hanging
out and
the way you said it seems like health
stuff just came out of nowhere
sounds like you're
almost uh
not quite buying into it
i'm definitely buying into it okay okay
okay
um so man
when you say you don't have time for
other stuff are you like
what type of care is she requiring
well
she'll be
like
she'll
swell up and i'll need to go and just
make sure that it doesn't get er bad
basically because i've had to take her
to the er a couple times okay uh
you know and i'm
she's
immobilized a lot of the time so i'm
taking care of our dog and just
everything we don't have kids yet thank
goodness even though that's on the
docket but it's also scary because
yeah
um now does it now doesn't sound like a
good season to
be bringing that level of complexity
into your home um what have the doctors
said what's the prognosis do they have
any idea of what's going on
yeah they're figuring it out they're
we're working on getting special types
of injections that should
uh
get her
good okay uh
should get her good so uh man so how can
i help
i just i don't know how to
balance this i'm
i'm out of i'm out of gas basically and
i can feel my heart starting to harden a
little bit in these areas and that
that's scaring me yeah
so
um
a couple of thoughts right away um
balance is a myth it's not real
it's not not a thing okay um burnout and
resentment and condescension those
things are very very real
so
in a season where hey somebody's really
sick
somebody's pregnant somebody lost a job
somebody fill in the blank what that's
going to be the rest of your life
there's going to be seasons
uh when we have a newborn and we have a
middle schooler and we have some
know-it-all high school that's going to
be seasons of your life
and so it's less about how do i balance
all this and it's more how do i stay
well and how do i function and operate
in whatever season i'm in meaning
when it's cold outside i'm gonna put a
jacket on and when it's cold outside i'm
not gonna go play soccer all night i may
have to run on a treadmill inside right
so we're still exercising so moving but
it's just gonna look different in that
season so
taking balance off the table give me a
list of a couple of things you need in
your life to be
well uh i need my personal time i need
some time to myself be way more specific
than that
because that's that benchmark will move
do you need an hour to play video games
do you need personal time like i need to
go to the gym
i need to go meet with a mentor or a
friend i need to go grab a drink with a
couple of buddies like what do you mean
by you time i
i need time with no
expectations where i'm not needed
uh so that could be going to the gym
that could be video games that could be
going and seeing a buddy but i just need
time where
you know
i'm not needed
so i'll
bad news is brother you got married
i know and i'll say bad news brother
you're a
member of
my country and bad news brother is
you're a member of a couple of
neighborhoods and communities and a
workplace
there will never be a moment for the
rest of your life where you're not
needed
unless
you unplug go back to your mom's
basement and never leave
okay yeah that doesn't sound too good no
so i want you to take the idea that
you're not needed that you don't have
purpose off
and replace that with i need
time for restoration i need time for
connection i need time for laughter i
need time for taking care of my physical
and psychological and spiritual mental
health
okay those things are all super good
because you can't be
present you can't help anybody you can't
be good at work or at home or as a dad
one day or as a friend if you're not
taking care of these other things
and but if just this idea of i want to
be off
i just want to get in my car and drive
away for a while the feeling i get but
the reality is um
you've made some choices and i mean
you're just
living in the world man so you're in
um
so let's i'm gonna drill down
and ask you a hard question
do you want to do some stuff do you want
some do you need some connection time do
you want to go to the gym you want to go
do some stuff with your buddies
are you just getting sick of
taking care of um your wife
and there's not a right or wrong answer
just be honest
probably both to be completely honest
okay
so i think it's important if you don't
if you don't look in the mirror and be
honest with what's really going on
inside of you you're not gonna be able
to act
and you're not gonna be able to do well
next every step you take if you're not
honest with what you see in the mirror
is gonna be some
uh some sort of addictive cover over
you're gonna go hang out you're gonna
get angry you're gonna get addicted to
anxiety you're gonna get depressed
you're gonna get addicted to those
chemicals too you're going to drink a
little bit more you're going to play a
little bit more video games you're going
to get a little more annoyed you got to
look in the mirror and say i it's not
what i signed up for and i need you to
hear me say it's okay to think that and
it's okay to feel that
all right you're not dysfunctional or
broken or a jerk for thinking good god
dude i'm eight months in and this is
this is what this is that's okay
it's what happens next that is about
character and metal and strength okay
and characters got two forms characters
got boundary forms and characters got
um
action
okay
so
sometimes taking care of somebody that
we love when it's exhausting
is a phone call it's not i'm not showing
up every second of every day you can't
be that for your wife for the rest of
everything you can't be all everything
all the time 24 7 365. you may need to
get some help do you have some family in
the area do you have some friends or
community do you have some skilled
nursing that could come be
be of assistance while you are
going to exercise where you're going to
a counselor or you're going to have to
stay at work a little bit make a little
bit more money
uh my sister's not far
i mean but she willing to help two
nights a week yeah yeah totally okay how
does that conversation happen in your
home if you say hey two nights a week i
need to go to the gym or i need to to go
fill in the blank
um and sister sarah's gonna come over
how does that go over
probably pretty well okay
so here's what i want you to do
i want you to be specific
and take the angst and frustration off i
think you're in a season you said the
doctors are working on this i think that
there's light at the end of this tunnel
right yeah totally so
this is season it's winter okay it's
just cold outside and don't lose hope
and don't give up and don't go running
into the woods and into the night
it's it's winter but i do want you to be
very very specific about your needs
and
doing nothing
having no responsibility is no longer an
option you got married
okay
um
talk be very specific about here's what
makes me well
it's been an hour or two with my friends
spend three hours with my friends once a
week um getting together with a group of
guys to go serve that's important to me
going to the gym three times a week
that's important to me and then there's
some of those things you're gonna have
to work around
like i have two little kids i used to
love going to the gym i used to love
spending all late into the night at the
mma gym i loved that i had a gang there
i loved it and then i had kids and so
i've had to move my gym into my garage
with a bunch of stuff i bought off
craigslist over the years
it's different and now i've come to love
it but i didn't have the hour anymore to
drive there hang out too long and then
drive back now i just do it at my house
right so some of those things i had to
shift and change because my life shifted
and changed and i got to decide whether
i whined and complained about it or i
chose to love what i had and now i love
what i've got you see what i'm saying
yeah yeah totally um and i need you to
make sure you find somebody that you can
be honest with
and what i mean by honest is that you
can say this week was really hard and
this week was pretty annoying it was
hard
and that that person's not going to beat
you up for they're not going to give you
a bunch of dumb advice they're not going
to judge you for it they're going to say
i'm sorry man
and pass the queso or i'm sorry man it's
your set to go lift
and then you can have somebody to talk
to because if you bottle that stuff up
and you don't say it you don't say it
and you don't say it it's gonna turn
into resentment and then this thing's
over
okay how close are you to
just walking out the door
uh i'm
be honest be honest you thought about it
how close are you
and not coming back very far from that
but running away for a day or two
probably pretty close okay
what what does the conversation look
like if you sit down with your wife and
say hey um
i'm gonna take a day and my sister is
gonna come
would she be like oh thank god i'm so
i'm so happy that you're gonna get away
for a day or would she say you're
abandoning me and you're leaving me and
i hate you
i feel like
if i had that conversation a month ago
it might be that but
now she would be
relieved probably okay
so
think about caring as you have to take
care of you too
and if you're not exercising if you're
not eating well if you're not sleeping
then the long-haul ability you have to
take care of her goes away
so taking care of you is an important
part of taking care of her making sure
you're well is an important part of
making sure she's well
hear what i'm saying
yeah that means you're gonna have to ask
for help
and here's the big picture
you had a picture of what marriage was
gonna be like and it's very very
different your wife probably had a
picture of what marriage was going to be
like too and it's very different for her
also so even though she's struggling
right now eight months in she's sick
you're having to take care of her it's
changed all your plans you had all these
dreams about how we were just going to
run around the house naked all the time
and having fun it was going to be crazy
we're going to go on vacations and now
sick exhausted tired you're not able to
hang out all those things
sit down with your wife and you'll be
honest with one another
because she's probably got some guilt
too she's probably upset too because she
had a different picture also
and let's spend a minute
crafting a new picture for what the next
two months is going to look like
just two months 60 days
um what's the next 60 days gonna look
like
i'm gonna be able to take care of you
here i need to take a day once a week
and i'm gonna make sure i've got to get
back in the gym and take care of it
myself so that i can show up and take
care of you my sister's gonna come
sometime sometimes i'm gonna be able to
go and you'll just call me on the cell
phone if i need something and let's get
a picture of what cara looks like make
sure y'all are both on the same page
both of y'all are working together and
my guess is when you all do that you're
both going to relax a little bit
and one of the greatest gifts you can
give a body that's struggling with
autoimmune issues that's struggling with
um an overactive inflammatory response
is
peace
it's peace
preachate you be an honest chance there
are millions of men and women in your
same situation right now who are
exhausted tired
they can't say the words out loud i'm
sick of this because i love my partner
but i'm sick of this so thanks for being
brave
now it's about what you do next we'll be
right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they don't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 percent off that's
betterhelp.com
all right all right we are back and
we're gonna go out to oh mandy oh mandy
in nashville what's up
how are you you never heard that one
before have you no never
hey listen my name rhymes with the lunch
meat so same team same team there you go
so what's up
uh well i just have a question um
i'll preface by saying i've been married
a while um 20 plus years my husband and
i i mean if i wrote down all the great
things about him
there are many he's amazing he loves his
family well
he loves the lord he's got like
so much going for him so i think over
the years i've just overlooked this one
thing a whole lot and now it's just come
to a point where i'm finally realizing
either i need to see it differently or
he needs to change i'm not sure
but he just has an anger
issue when i say that um he would not we
have two girls in college he would never
yell at me he would never yell at them
and no one would ever you know fear that
he just he's very kind so he's kind of
it's a complex thing he's this kind
gentle bear on the inside but
his office is in our home and when he
gets frustrated
he yells loudly and it's uh to the point
where um
when my girls were little
i would take them out or whatever and um
but now that they're older and gone i
just it's it's a
it's it's a thing and i don't know if i
just need to like
suck it up and and not worry about him
yelling but it's like i'll give you an
example because i started writing down a
couple of times it's happened so that
if i needed to go and figure out
counseling just to help me know how to
deal with it better or
whatever
but like right before thanksgiving my
girlfriend home from college we were
cooking in the kitchen and um his office
is right by the kitchen he was
frustrated with some circumstances and
just yelling off and on throughout the
day so we're in there like you know
trying to have fun
and cook for thanksgiving it just like
makes everybody feel on edge and puts a
damper
on everything and i also just feel like
i'm apologizing for his behavior too
much
try to find an excuse for it but
they've grown up with it with him in the
home
and like i said if they needed something
they could walk in his office and he's
there for him but but if if he's having
a bad day you just never know when it's
coming and yelling
so one of my daughters just kind of like
ignores it and acts like it's not
happening the other one um she's
definitely been i guess they've both
been equally affected they just deal
with it differently but she just like
she can't stand it and
like me and it just um i don't know it
just it will
squash all of us a little bit and so
i don't know the best way to he knows
and we i mean i'll talk openly to him
and he just feels like he doesn't
know what to do with the stress that
he's under and he doesn't
um
he just don't know what to do with it so
then i feel bad like well
am i expecting too much for him but then
i'm like it to me it seems like a temper
tantrum so i don't know
but you know so mandy how how number one
thank you for
thank you for your call um this this
affects a lot of folks and so your
willingness to be brave here is going to
be helpful for folks
um
i asked this with some rare rarity um
how honest can i be
oh 100
are you positive
oh yeah okay yeah i i yes i seek truth
some people say that and then i tell
them they're like ooh i didn't seek that
the type of yelling you're describing is
abuse
and it is trauma
and
the way you preface talking about this
man that you love and that i believe is
a good guy i believe that he loves his
kids i believe he loves you i believe he
works hard to provide
is the way
when i've had behind closed doors
discussions with people who are
physically abused who are sexually
abused it always starts with the same
okay let me tell you this first he's
great he's wonderful he's so lovely he's
this and this and this but there's just
one thing
and so i need you to hear me say that
the way you even preface this discussion
is
verbatim how i have these conversations
with folks who have what i what the
world would say is more traditional
um abusive behavior
here's why it's abusive
for your daughter's entire life
they have had to um
regulate
they have been responsible for the
emotions of an adult male in their home
and they have had to learn how to
control the adult emotions in the home
because the adult in the house couldn't
do it himself
and so what they have taken on
themselves is this peacekeeping role
this hey we gotta hide or some kids take
on
i don't care i'm gonna flex back right
those are all adaptive trauma responses
to an unstable emotional environment
that they have felt like they have to
control and how this works downhill
is they're going to find somebody else
to marry
that they feel like they have to
emotionally regulate or they have to
hide themselves completely
even the question and
those two responses are relatively
common either way and you may notice
that in both of your daughters and
how genetics plays in how personal
experience plays in
it's can often baffle parents like the
same dad is like this kid's doing that
and this one's doing that
it tends to be the same response it just
looks different right or the root
response is different
so
most of us look at people we love and
the word abuse makes us recoil like no
he's not abusive
yeah if you find yourself apologizing
because people in your home are
uncomfortable about behavior if you find
yourself saying hey kids let's just get
out for a minute while dad does what
he's doing
um
so begin to think through that lens and
you'll usually the light comes on and
people go oh my goodness and here's one
that that um is common
you know who you've begun to really be
uncertain about
you
you have dealt with this for so long
that you are willing to go get
counseling so that you can learn how to
deal with somebody who's throwing a
grown-up temper tantrum
and here's so so when you stop trusting
you
or you start outsourcing your trust to
somebody else that's a cornerstone of
hey i'm not my body recognizes i'm not
safe in this environment
and so
who taught him this somebody showed him
that this is how you respond to things
i
don't i don't exactly know his um i mean
his
i i really his dad is um
definitely short tempered but i don't
see him yelling um
so some dads let me catch so some dads
they don't yell
they become radioactive
i call it the uh silent violence
they
are a imp you know if i touch that bear
it will bite my arm off and so everybody
back away or he says that one sentence
and everyone knows this conversation's
officially over
right right and so that is the same
physiological response we have when
someone's yelling their head off
and when i say somebody learned this let
me say that in a better way
um
somebody told your husband that his
thoughts and feelings didn't matter
they need to keep them to himself
somebody told him that i don't care how
you feel you will sit down on your butt
and you will shut your mouth while i
that's
that's the picture he received
and it lodges in and lodges in until it
absolutely explodes
and so when he's yelling who is he
yelling at
well that's just like
he just yells words like he just he's
frustrated with a situation and then he
just feels like the pressure's too much
or you know he's
he's always had the um excuse i could
just i mean you know for a long i mean
i've been working the last few years but
before that he was the primary provider
so just the pressure of all that he
would stay with the
it would just get to him and like he
wanted to but yet
but so he would just something's going
wrong at work uh it's just yelling it's
it's you know it's
into the air yeah it's at the situation
so so it's it's into the air but it's
into your nervous system
right it's into the nervous system of
your daughters
right so
um here's what here's here's the lens i
want to paint right and here's the thing
if he showed up here this afternoon was
like you just told my wife i'm abusive i
would say yes i did
yeah okay if he came to see me and i was
a licensed psychologist and he sat down
with me i was a licensed counselor he
sat down with me i would tell him
that the response you are um to things
that aren't going your way
is how my six-year-old responds
and somehow there's a six-year-old still
running the show for him and i don't say
that in a condescending he's acting like
a baby
but there's something there's some
six-year-old in him that's still trying
to protect him
there's some seven or eight or nine year
old that was told some things that he's
still cycling in on okay
so a couple of things
i want you to start considering yelling
as trauma
and i think any sort of trauma response
you're going to have too one that you've
felt and then there's going to come a
moment as you process this and there's
going to be a a wave of guilt that comes
if it hasn't already which is i'm my
daughter's mom and i should have
protected her right okay all right and
if you sit on that for a minute i bet
it's hard to keep the tears back
yep
and so
that's where a gift you can provide your
daughters and your husband
is to say i haven't um been true to
myself and i haven't been true to my
daughters for however many years
and daughters
i'm sorry that i didn't get involved
earlier your dad was never gonna hurt
anybody here i was safe and i didn't
know what to do and i thought it was on
me and it's not this isn't okay
and here is where moving forward you
can't control his behavior only he can
the only thing that you can control is
you
so you need two things
you need a good boundary
and you need choices you're in now
so the boundary is he needs to know in
no uncertain terms that when yelling
happens
you
choose to disconnect
and here's why your choice is important
not he's making you because that's what
yelling does it protects us
it's a seven or eight or nine-year-olds
response to a radius blast everybody get
out of my way i'm overwhelmed my
my ability to respond to this has been
uh
it's overwhelmed
you take the power back
and say when you yell
i am choosing to leave
because when you yell you are choosing
to tell me that you don't want me here
okay
and so i want you to own that boundary
because i don't think your husband wants
to hurt you
no but i also think he has chosen not to
find different ways to deal with his
things not going his way
you see how the both of those are trying
to disconnect like where do you take
like how far are you taking that because
i i automatically shut down when he does
it and
he knows emotionally i'm just like
checked out went
for a little while
yeah and so instead of
um
i i i just say when you choose to do
that then you're choosing to not have
dinner with me and i'm going to go get
dinner by myself
okay or i'm choosing to go have friends
not that i'm moving out unless you feel
unsafe you know i mean that's not saying
at all no no no but i am too you you are
have chosen to violate a boundary
yelling's not okay i don't feel safe in
my home when you do that my body turns
into a raw pile of nerves when you do
that
um
and i get sick to my stomach at how our
daughters are gonna meet men who think
this is an okay way to respond to them
to their kids to situations that they
that are out of their control
um and you
are gonna choose to leave and here's
what's going to happen
he's going to call your bluff or he's
just not going to think about it or it's
going to come out actually he's been
doing this a long time okay and again
i'm not hating on him at all he's this
is a behavior it's going to have to
change it it's hard it's probably been a
lifelong thing
so it will happen and then you will
stick to your guns
and he'll get mad at you for making that
choice
and that's the moment of clarity
when he can choose to not hurt his wife
he can choose to learn different ways to
deal with this
and it's going to be practice for him
and it's gonna be hard and there's gonna
be a lot of grace involved but i've set
my boundary here
yeah and my guess is um
i've just heard the stories i've talked
to a few folks but the big stories are
when you want to stop yelling you stop
yelling
i will learn something else i will go
for a walk outside i will get up and i
will do 30 push-ups i will
immediately turn my computer off and
spin in my chair ten times i will find a
way yeah
but i'm going to stop creating an unsafe
space in my home can i ask you this when
you talk to him about this when you've
said i don't feel safe when you yell
what's his response
i mean he's
very like he's always been very open to
to listening to anything i would have to
say and i can say whatever to him but
he's
like the last
time i talked about he just said he
really just doesn't know what else to do
he's like i don't and he isn't like this
last two weeks they're under
more stress than enormous a normal um
couple weeks in his office so it's just
been
um
yeah he just he doesn't he really
doesn't know
that there's another way if that makes
any sense i don't i don't and and for so
for me i've been like am i
am i expecting too much no absolutely
not absolutely not um where i want to
see
a man in that situation
be real brave be be
the epitome
of concrete strength of of taking his
power back
is recognizing that
without meaning to i'm hurting the three
most important people on planet earth to
me
and
i don't want to hurt them anymore so i
have to be about learning new things
that to me is the single strongest
somebody who can say the words i was
wrong
and i needed to do something different
and here's what that's going to look
like
wow well that's a counselor well that's
getting with a couple of buddies call
tell him to call my show i i absolutely
don't hate the guy i think he's um
get these under pressure the whole
world's under pressure right now right
right right and every time we're under
pressure we have a choice
we have a choice and what's hard for me
is that you've told him your particular
choice hurts us
and his response has been
i don't know anything else so here we go
and so the ball is in your court to draw
a boundary and to be clear and when i
say clear this isn't a yelling this is
gentle this is quiet this is right right
hey the last two weeks has pushed me
past where i'm comfortable anymore
and the days of me apologizing for you
and your behavior are over now
and here's here's
here's my new boundary
when you yell
you're choosing
i'm choosing to disconnect and leave
and i'm going to go have dinner by
myself
and if yelling is more important than
being with me so be it feel free to yell
but this i'm not going to be in the
house for anymore i deserve to be safe i
deserve to feel safe i deserve to not
feel like you're gonna go off at any
moment
and quite frankly you deserve
a better avenue for dealing with this
the beauty is there's a lot of
opportunities to heal from yelling and
um i just didn't tell you mandy i'm so
grateful for you and for
your willingness to call in the show
thank you so much we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back cracker jacks
let's go to phoenix
and talk to mrs shawna what's up shauna
hey doctor john how's it going man we
are rocking onto the brink of dawn how
about you
i'm all right um
really how are you i just heard about
your accident am i right oh man
yeah i guess the show went out today um
yeah i'm getting there it's uh my
something happened to my ribs man i'm
still not breathing right but um i'm
doing i'm doing good i'm doing good i
did get the uh
estimate back on the prius and the
breeze officially
prius is dead the prius is gone
no more so such it is but thank you for
asking you're too kind
heck of a way to start the day i tell
you what that's exactly right
so what's up yeah so the reason for my
call is i'm really concerned about my
husband because
he has no friends
and when i say
he has no friends i mean he has
zero
nobody that he gets together with hangs
out with
calls up has a beer
dinner whatever
nobody the only person he talks to aside
from me is his mom uh-oh
how old is he yeah
he is going to be 64 this year oh okay
yeah so his mom is mom
has mom always been
uh
yeah
kind of like the
jellyfish with the tentacles around
everything
uh-huh yes you've been married to two
people most of your marriage
you know that's exactly what my
counselor has said three people in your
marriage yes i'm making this up as i go
that feels good
um wow
oh man yeah
so so
something's happened recently where
you're concerned what's going on
um
mom is you know certainly she's not
going to be around forever she's getting
up there in age and he can't even talk
about it you know just like
we talked about you know wills and and
trusts and all that so he won't even
broach the subject
period
so it's like
it's gonna happen someday yep
i'm the only one
here for you and
you know i just don't think it's healthy
so it's it's absolutely absolutely not
um
and it's not the fact that he's a 65
year old man who loves his mom and takes
care of mom that's that's not the
unhealthy part the unhealthy part is
they're still acting as though she's 22
and he's six
yeah
um he just brought you along for that
ride
yeah how long have you all been there
i think the table's turned i think he's
the one that's 22 and she's six oh
because she just hovers over her wow
how's your marriage
um it's
we struggle yeah we're in counseling
um i think
we've struggled for a long time and i
think the only reason that we're
together is we're both committed to
making it work
but you're not making it work
we're struggling yeah but we're in
counseling and and you know
so you're not making some progress for
the first time good so you're not
committed to making it work you're
committed to not quitting
because commitment to making it work
means we're gonna have super hard
conversations and i'm i'm going to and
he's going to do things that are really
uncomfortable for us to grow so it
sounds like you're committed to not
ending it but you're
you're getting there and i and here let
me say this
the fact that he's willing to go is a
real brave step i don't know a lot of
that courageous and that strong of men
who at 65 will say i need to go talk to
somebody with my wife because we're not
okay good for him that's good and good
for you for dragging him kicking and
screaming um and that was it yeah hey
he wasn't like he went willingly sure
so ultimately i
this might be unfair and i don't care
i want you in your home and with your
counselor to begin to discuss his
relationship with his mom as an
addiction
because what she
not her
but his interaction with her his
relationship with her is allowing him to
numb out and not deal with reality and
that's what addiction is
and so the only way to deal with
addiction is to
get off the drug
and so when we think about it in terms
of relationship we say i can't leave mom
hanging i can't mom has to i have to
right so we make it about a bunch of
tasks and a bunch of obligations and a
bunch of shoulds
if you spend a season looking at mom as
heroin
that is killing us that is killing you
then now we're going to approach dealing
with that relationship differently
and that might mean for a season that
you
are the one who's going to go over and
make sure your mom's gutters are or
you're going to call the guy that's
going to fix the gutters and you might
be the one that goes over and talks to
mom about the will the conversation with
the will is happening if you don't want
to do it fine i'm going to be the one
right so that may be that you fill in
the gap for a little while which is
absolutely not something you want to do
with your other wife right but
it may be the way that he slowly weans
himself off but if he doesn't
man hey
when this call's over hang on the line
i'm going to send you a copy of my new
book own your past change your future
and it's
oh you did well i'm gonna send you
another one that way y'all can read it
together okay
um
but
something about his past it says
marriage is not safe somebody else isn't
safe this is become this interaction
with mom he totally controls interesting
feels like a warm blanket for him so
what about
your marriage is unsafe
well
for him his his ex-wife
walked out on him
all coming together james we should
start a podcast
yeah we should do this for a living so
he has
um
the first most important one or the
second most important woman in his life
after mom walked out on him
gone
right
so his body
remembers that
and so i blamed mom for being a
jellyfish and you corrected me and you
corrected me correctly so he wrapped his
tentacles around the first most
important woman in his life and said
this will be it
and then he wanted some romance and you
can't kiss your mom so he got married
again and he i'm confident he loves you
right how long have you all been married
uh 13 years okay so you all been in it
for more than a decade
um
but there's it i would be stunned if
there wasn't some side eye in the side
of so in the
special parts of his brain that are just
waiting for you to leave
oh i agree with that 100 percent and
what becomes
becomes oh he said that okay so here's
what stinks about that
is
for whatever reason or those kind of
thoughts become self-reinforcing
and when there's a part of his brain
waiting for something to happen
then it leans one centimeter away from
the the blast or two inches away from
the blast
and you feel that gap
and you respond to that gap whether
you're conscious of it or not with
either being overly clingy or he just
needs a space and i'm just gonna go do
this and then you look up 10 years later
and you've created a life he's created a
life and you're still sharing a bed
exactly
and then you get that two inches apart
two thousand miles away from each other
yeah um
and while he has
no friends i have a lot of friends yep
so
um is he unpleasant to be around i'm
just being honest like if you invited a
couple some couples over to the house
and
they're
you know
unsociable husbands showed up is he fun
to be around or did he go hide in the
back room
he no he's fun to be around
um i don't know that he
i mean actually when there's other
people around i kind of look at him and
i'm like who are you because you are not
that person at home
but um
i don't know that he's comfortable in
that environment i mean i do get us
together with other couples
um not frequently but um
he's fine he seems fine in those
situations
but the fact that he doesn't have
friends leads me to believe i mean i
don't know what's going on between him
and
other guys like that he used to work
with or whatever
so one of the great tragedies of our
time is the loneliness of adult men
we have no our dads didn't i mean our
dads didn't have friends
our dads went to work and worked
themselves to death literally if you
look at the data
and we don't have a picture of what
adult male friendship looks like
and so
and then man we create fantasy leagues
and we create video games we create
streaming services and now we really
don't have to leave
and now making adult male friends as an
adult is
um
one of the physiologically scariest
things our bodies can absorb because we
want to belong
and that's not a want like i just want
to belong
that's a that's a core psychological
physiological need
the other side of that which is really
hard to interp to come to grips with is
when our body recognizes that we're
lonely it goes to war against us
and so you either have to risk
and lean over that edge and say i know i
need friends
or
you die a painful
slow
incapacitating death and you take people
around you with you
and that's why you're calling
so i yeah i've tried to encourage him
i'm like why don't you call someone on
google finger why don't you call someone
you know he just feels like it i think
there's more to it as well as as far as
the lack of
you know it's like well they've got
other things that's my life i'm a burden
i know that they need to take care of it
yeah exactly i'm a burden they don't
want to hang out with me or
we're going to get to hole five of the
golf course and i don't know i don't
know what we're gonna talk about so i'm
just let's just stay here
or i talked to one guy who was like man
why would i go skiing i'm just gonna get
up water skiing i'm just gonna get up
i'm gonna get my swim trunks on go get
the boat in the water then we're gonna
drive around and get all hot and i'm
gonna end up back and then we're gonna
get tired i'm gonna end up in the same
chair that this tonight why don't you
stay here
and
if you're running low if you're lonely
if you're depressed if you are if
relationships have hurt you in the past
that has a logic to it it makes sense
it's true we are we're gonna end up
right back here
um
and unfortunately you end up missing all
of life whether it's movement whether
it's outdoors whether it's nature
whether it's companionship and
friendship etc
the only way i've seen this thing shift
is to one of two ways one is
it's by association
one of the one of the partners so in
this case you
says hey from this point forward every
friday night we're having
these couples over
and just truth be told my wife do that
to me
um
i i've had some deep bouts of profound
loneliness in my life and what really
stinks about that is i've got
men and women in my life who i love and
i've been friends with for years and
years and years but i have a tendency to
isolate myself
i just get home and i'm tired and i just
loop a blanket of the distraction around
me and then i call it good so she said
we're having people over every weekend
forever for the rest of our lives
and so
what i had to come to terms with was
there's always going to be people in my
house and so i can make peace with it or
i can go to war with it and i decided to
make peace with it and now i
i miss it dearly
that's number one number two was i had a
stark oh my goodness um
it's john uh
c-a-c-c-i-p-p-o
casiapo is that how you say it
wrote the he wrote the book called
loneliness and i read that book as a
scientist and
i remember
it was like reading a book about the
damages of smoking or reading a book
about you know particular nutrition
stuff it was a bellwether moment i
bought it for multiple people in my life
but i read it and realized oh if you
don't do this you're gonna die
it's gonna kill you and it's gonna be
real unpleasant way to die too by
strokes and cancer and heart disease and
things like that and so those two things
the ra the reality of that data helped
me to change and my wife's commitment to
i'm just gonna surround you with people
you're gonna get over this or you're
just gonna have to go sit under under
our bed while the house is full of
people who love you
and i opted for number two
and it's it's uh i'm super super
grateful that she leaned in that way and
i've got friends who won't let me won't
let me go either and vice versa but
um
it sounds like you've got that extra
thing where you have friends and that's
kind of one of the reasons that i reach
out to you because i i in listening to
your show for so long i know that you
value friendship it's everything and
yeah and it's sad that he has it and his
mom doesn't either yeah not like yeah
it's a model he doesn't have he doesn't
have a picture for it
um and there's a few men in my life like
todd and john and trevor and craig and
others that they taught me what
friendship looked like ryan and caleb
and chris these guys have been in my
life for years and years for decades and
decades they taught me what it looks
like
they kept showing up right and so it's
hard when you don't have that
that's where
your influence in his life will be big
and a counselor's influence in his life
will be big
the the
the challenge with trauma especially
when it comes relational trauma whether
it's any type of uh sexual abuse or
physical abuse or any type of abuse is
it weaponizes the very thing that keeps
us alive it weaponizes a relationship so
somewhere in there
relationships equal scary relationships
equal pain and until he decides i'm
gonna make a move past that
um he's gonna continue to choose safety
which makes total sense i get it
um but yeah mom's gonna go and all
sudden yet another important woman in
his life is going to be gone
and you you almost you see that car
wreck happening in slow motion right
yeah yeah
so number one he's lucky to have you
like
the number of men who would call my show
and be like dude i wish my wife would
tell me to go golfing or fishing or
something good for you good for loving
him so much that you know that he needs
other people that's amazing yeah number
two i would make a commitment to the
house is gonna be full of people
and i see you husband come alive when we
do this and so we're gonna do it and
then the third thing is
i would be really clear in your
counseling sessions in your counseling
meetings
to talk about his loneliness your desire
for him to have friends
your commitment to put money out there
or time out there whatever that looks
like
and let's be really clear about the data
the data of loneliness
so let's do this we're going to take a
break real quick we're going to come
back and i'll run through a little bit
of that data with you um stay on the
line sean we're going to send you
another copy of the book that you can
read give him and y'all can read it
together and um
man i'm so grateful that you called let
us know how this thing plays out because
i'm interested and my hope is that he
gets a couple of grumpy old men that
will join him in whatever adventures
he's he wants to go on here for the last
20 30 years of his life we'll be right
back
big secret almost all of us can control
our thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be so go to
johndaloni.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we're back um follow up on
that last call
about loneliness here um
so i hear the word lonely over and over
again from all people all walks of life
and we know loneliness is pervasive and
we've even started to hear terms like
the loneliness epidemic i've said things
like that
um
we
beneath that we live our lives we set
them up as though we don't need anyone
else and and as though every
every social trend we have is how can
you be self-reliant how can you do these
things by yourself
and we've created this myth over the
last
20 30 40 50 60 years 100 years that
we believe we can save ourselves by
ourselves and we are all that matters
from the time where kids were taught the
story that were responsible for all of
all of it everything our personal growth
our development our attitude our grades
our money and here's the thing we are
personal responsibility is huge and we
have thrown that out the window
but those things don't make us okay they
don't make us well and when you chase
personal growth development fix your
attitudes you try to get straight a's
you try to make a bajillion dollars
and you try to do everything by yourself
you get to the finish line of whatever
goal you have and the goal moves and the
goal moves because you're unanchored
you're untethered the goal's untethered
it's unanchored why why are you even
doing this
and so
yes we have personal responsibility
but as you've heard me say i'm trying to
craft a new third way
it's both and it's personal
responsibility and
you have to have relationships it's both
it's both these these things that we get
that we accomplish we achieve
don't make us well they're hollow we
will
die
you will
die
our brains and bodies are literally
wired for connection we need people to
know love protect mate work with all
these things but because we can't be
well alone you've heard me say this a
thousand times loneliness is more deadly
than smoking it's associated with
personality disorders impaired cognitive
performance and premature death
premature death now think of the
alternative here
joy playing having fun having people to
cry with to laugh with to lift with to
golf with if you're a golfer god help
you to fish with to hunt with whatever
it is to drive cars with to play legos
with i don't care i'll even say to play
fortnite with
you fortnight people right
deep healthy relationships can heal us
from
physical pain from loss from trauma and
i know that sounds silly because i want
a pill for my trauma
i was just talking to somebody yesterday
who lost their wife somebody who i loved
dearly
and it was
just returned from an event where it was
folks who were just dealing with loss of
their spouse and
this person's super brave super strong
but we talked about
it was just being with other people who
were hurting and saying the story out
loud how is that healing it just is
grief demands a witness and when you
give it one your body begins to go oh
i'm not alone
if you want to be well and you want your
life to be a little bit better tomorrow
than it is today and a lot better down
the line
set down the story that you can save
yourself that you can achieve yourself
that you can win yourself you can crush
and kill it and yourself
to some sort of
wellness to some sort of
peace
let me say that again
peace
you got to get connected in real
relationships and so hey man this pitch
is right into i got a whole chapter on
this in the new book
ma'am the story that you can save
yourself is just one of the stories that
i just
dig way into in the new book on your
past change your future covers trauma
connection everything and most
importantly what do i do about all this
stuff right what do i do remember if you
pre-order this book today um
if you pre-ordered the book today you
get over 300 bucks you know i can't put
a dollar amount on it there's different
states it regulates but
hundreds of dollars of
free stuff
most importantly you get a month of free
therapy from better help our friends at
better health believe in this book and
they believe in you and they stepped up
man it's time to stop being lonely and
if you want to step by step here's how
you do that pre-order the book man i'd
love for you to check it out check it
out check it out as we wrap up today's
show we're gonna go with
let's say the godmother and the
godfather the one and only nina simone
off the silk and soul record
song goes like this
i wish i knew how it would feel to be
free i wish i could break all the chains
holding me i wish i could say all the
things i should say
say i'm loud say i'm clear for the whole
round world to hear i wish i could share
all the love that's in my heart remove
all the bars that keep us apart i wish
you could know what it means to be me
then you'd see and agree that every man
should be free
i wish i could give all i'm longing to
give i wish i could live like i'm
longing to live i wish i could do all
the things that i can do though i'm way
overdue i'd be starting anew and that's
what we're doing here we're starting
anew we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode uh so my
dad he had an affair
that divorce wasn't your fault nolan
you believe me when i say that i want to
believe it but sometimes it's hard i
know and there's a 12 year old in there
that's still trying to figure out what
in the world you did to split them up
like she'll have thoughts telling her to
hurt herself but she's like i don't want
to do that the university doesn't really
offer what they say they're going to
offer i'm angry on your behalf that
anyone would ever tell an undergraduate
student hey uh just check on him if she
sees someone that looks like him
it's the same thing
she just kind of goes into this panic
tell me about
sexual intimacy y'all good things oh
that's fantastic
sorry uh we party brother no don't be
don't apologize
[Music]